valérie le live prendra la place julien
de compétences et que de la télé c'est
officiel ça a été validé par la chaîne
voilà tout le monde est d'accord tout le
monde est heureux valérie vous me direz
ce que vous en pensez
et si vous êtes heureuse pour l'instant
je vais demander tient jean luc lemoine
dit la vérité et je dis la vérité je
trouve que c'est la logique ultime de
maître valérie déjà elle était
remplaçante de jeu de julien courbet
j'aurais pas compris que ce soit
quelqu'un d'autre que valait rien et
c'est pas juste au mérite parce que de
toute façon elle est compétente pour ça
elle et elle est très à l'aise dans cet
exercice et on l'a vu sur 7 à vous quand
ces analyses et les domaines qui a
remplacé la titulaire ça s'est très bien
passé parce que c'était c'est exactement
ça la même logique c'est exactement la
logique à laquelle on a pensé voilà jean
luc poli le mcs matthieu delormeau
écoutez je suis important de savoir la
vérité
on peut dire que j'ai refusé le poste re
ah non c'est pas vrai qu'à traces
derrière proposé j'ai maintenant je
propose un poste de radio
non évidemment c'est logique qu'elle
l'ait j'aime beaucoup
j'ai pas de souci avec ça l'essentiel
c'est une mauvaise locomotive pour tpm
paie donc on doit débarquer et là je
reprendrai la place de la gare dray
comme chroniqueuse que j'aime beaucoup
aller alors de leurs maux déjà c'est une
vaste hypocrisie à hilla fracassant
loges et là comme il a peur pour
vulgaire imagem de leur mouvement n'est
pas fracasser benhaim real est allé moi
j'aime pas du tout pourquoi parce que
valérie benaïm c'est la diva la reine
des dominos là la vraie grande émission
prétendument et là vous vous battez pour
une émission à 18 heures mais ce n'est
pas une attitude essayé à si si si si
vous avez intrigué pour avoir les
missions et battez vous pour des primes
si vous êtes une grande animatrice
fenomeno rider pas de bêtise voire le 18
heures en quotidienne peut avoir
quelques prime vous dites quoi non mais
elles pourraient se battre pour autre
chose
d'autre part selon des indiscrétions que
j'ai elle veut absolument faire cette
émission pour ne plus faire touche pas à
mon poste et ne plus avoir son opinion
de toute façon elle ne l'a donné jamais
son opinion
alors si sylvie n'est d'accord moi je
reste autant de jours que je me suis
restée toute cette année sur touche pas
à mon poste parce que j'adore faire du
compost sera votre priorité après c'est
que la télé en plus mais tous proposent
tetra laval est révélée comme elle l'a
fait cette année
exagéré du coup la vérité ce que vous
êtes content moi je suis aux anges
mais vraiment je suis aux anges j'ai
passé une année formidable à remplacer
julien vous m'avez gentiment avec vue
avec julie a proposé de prendre la suite
et et vous m'avez dit des gentils mots
et donc j'étais très très très heureuse
et je j'ai envie de me déchirer sur
cette émission vous vous allez pouvoir
garder la même bande
oui bah oui allez merci
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]